citizens of the reject Nation we are
here once again for the Last of Us seven
of nine it's the Star Trek crossover
episode and joining me once again is my
very excellent co-host Tara Erickson
Tara how you doing today hi guys dude
I'm so excited are you excited yes I am
dude it's still pouring rain outside
it's the perfect dreary weather for a
Last of Us episode why don't you guys go
ahead first and foremost follow Tara uh
go go you got some new stuff going down
right you're trying to do so right
please follow Ellie eats and drinks on
Instagram it's also on Tick Tock and
YouTube but I'm going around to
restaurants and bars and cool places
taking video editing them and doing a
little voice over and just get up on
there you know and support it as well as
subscribe hit the like button for this
Channel and don't forget to ring the
bell
foreign
[Music]
you get it and the patreon check out our
patreon.com the real rejects if you want
to sync up and watch the full experience
see everything that gets cut out of
these reaction highlights you can also
check out the watch along for Greg and
Andrew's video check out the reaction
highlights as well and uh hey if you
want to rock some real reject swag go on
look at our xeroddition.com store got
tons of stuff to keep you warm during
these waning winter months including
Greg's new game over design inspired by
The Last of Us and uh Hey without
further Ado I think we're ready to go
let's do it let's do
[Applause]
foreign
oh yeah you were supposed to be working
on the song and I was supposed to be
working on my fungus costume wow that's
where we're failing this week
if you for those of you playing along at
home I'm sorry no updates
next week for the whole musical number
and for the last episode I'll
I'll wear something fungacy
sinister
feel the chill
she dragged him all the way here
come on
fighter Joel leave shut up Joe shut the
[__] up
you're gonna die an old old woman warm
in your bed
not here
is life
oh
ouch there's no way she's coming back
that was a strong silence just there
oh
we go we're going to do a flashback
I think I have that walk man
laughs
[Applause]
oh I hated PE
I clearly excelled
I have PTSD just watching this
p-e-t-s-d all right
oh come on dude pick up your pace I
don't want to fight about it your friend
twice
she's not here anymore is she what okay
yes
that was you and P yeah
never been when I called well behaved
but the last few weeks
you got spunk kid we need more of that
around here you're promoted you're smart
Ellie Ellie you're so smart you're
stupid
you do take [__] or
probably be Bethany
naughty dog all the rules you become an
officer you get to tell the bethanies of
the world exactly where to shove it
in their bum so which way
jeez
good
pep talk
hey this otter be good dang wait [__]
that means she had a joke book all the
way back then
deep does the pun book go oh so she's
already lost people so she can't lose
Joel oh
Mortal Kombat
that's where Ellie got it
oh Riley Where Have You Been what the
[__] is wrong with you sneaking up on me
like that it was a joke okay in my mind
you loved it a storm read damn
you've been gone for three weeks where
were you
damn toughest nails
I joined the fireflies you
I'm not in the mood for this Riley I'm
really not
you're a firefly Jesus
come with me for a few hours and have
the best night of your life
it's 2 A.M in a few hours I have drills
get dressed not anymore
oh boy ain't nothing bad gonna happen
today
take on that cassette where are we going
you trust me right
I don't know should I trust you of
course you should with your life
can you trust Ellie with your life
guards no
dispatcher's [__] stupid
[Music]
maybe you should stop [__] with
Bethany I'm sorry you're telling me not
to beat people up you put Carol in the
infirmary for a [__] week you can
pick and choose what's important oh are
they teaching you this at Firefly
University kinda
Fu nice and Gerald
Carol yeah Carol
always hated Carol
oh Firefly lights are better one point
for the anarchists we prefer Freedom
Fighters whatever Firefly Freedom
Fighter good alliteration all around
oh [__]
oh no this guy wasn't here yesterday
surprise no thank you
score they're gonna get smashed
smash no one told him he couldn't mix
pills with that [__]
I think
oh my great oh my goodness
okay that's a good fake out
yum
I do not approve of this underage
drinking I do supposed to be a role
model
they're about to have somewhere the kids
come to these reactions
I got bored so I snuck out I was on my
way back and this chick popped out of
nowhere like 40.
whatever anyways old
said she was impressed watching me sneak
around she's like all right
if you wanted
and in a way Federal kind of holds
everything together as much as I love
arguing with your stubborn ass
you're on a mission here oh rooftop
Chase parkour
I guess Federer stands for the fascist
oh I had it damn you had a whole
accident you only got one word one word
I'll get it I'll get there okay
fascist Ensemble of dumbass racist
[__] there you got it
fireflies blowing up the stories people
didn't help
again the [__] yeah so you don't
bomb stuff anymore
now when civilians are around that's
propaganda
the mall you out of your [__] mind
they sealed that place off for a reason
it's full of infected it's sealed off
then why isn't it sealed off propaganda
let's go shopping
Montage that's trying on clothes but
they're all covered in Vines and foliage
this is where they find their virus
outfit apocalypse Chic we're gonna go
through there
then turn right you'll see a door go
through it wait are you gonna kill me
this seems like a perfect place to do it
oh I'm aware
what what is this gonna be is it a
surprise party
I'm here now what
be needing that
yes yes yes
oh wow yes
I love it oh look at the whole place to
yourself and you ain't seen nothing yet
tonight I'm going to show you the four
wonders of them all
you plan stuff
oh it's like a little date I ship them
I'm sure Riley is Alive and Well in the
present I ship them electric stick
[Music]
escalator temporarily stairs
except not not at the moment
stairs temporarily escalator
this is so
cool backwards
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's a good exercise
[Music]
careful are you
up
oh that was a little high smell love oh
me cute right there why are some of
these drawers empty and some not stuff
that's gone is the stuff that people
need it the most
sneakers
and not soap
or that [__]
I mean I don't get what
[Laughter]
looks uncomfortable
what nothing I was just trying to
imagine you wearing them shut up oh
golly all right come on
you're almost there
oh
Eleanor
so cute it's okay you're perfect sister
you're already halfway there yeah
come on oh
I love how they're building this up
gradually open your eyes
wowie what
what well has a carousel I want that
mall dang cool beautiful
well hers and hers horse ride
oh
all right
pour one out for that dead guy he really
hooked you up tonight
[Music]
oh why now come on dang you know we can
make things better
sewage detail
standing guard while people shovel [__]
that's what they think of me
oh
you know you're the one thing I miss
from that place
if that makes a difference
no
kiss
kiss I know right we're two wonders down
three more to go if you want to keep
going I don't know how it's supposed to
get better
oh you'll see rooftop swimming pool
oh photos the photo booth this is the
best date ever that's so cute this is
where the kiss is gonna happen I'm oh
you I came prepared have you done this
before idiot I was waiting to do it with
you
oh
where'd you get that fiber
oh [__] um
Jerry just care okay
okay
sorry oh
oh my goodness I love the tension ah I
feel it all
listen
yeah let's do this awesome
show me to the pinball this is the most
beautiful thing I've ever seen
oh what not not me you ball it up not
your buddy Riley where's the ski ball
where's Mortal Kombat oh yeah
not a ripoff of Mars Attacks coins you
can't even play once
[Laughter]
yeah I'm the same [__] that spent an
hour yesterday
breaking this
oh you're really prepared
best date ever dude
uh you ready test your might test your
mic but who do they each play as
it's the real question
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
let's do some creepy dolls in this story
why not
to
um
[Music]
oh yes oh boy
oh Network the network has awakened
[Music]
way to go Baraka
so close please die by butter lettuce
head and never get to kiss I have to
wake up and move my bed soon
we we still have a few hours left yeah I
just can't get in trouble again
I got you a gift
oh
I do like gifts
is it a spider
[Music]
is it in your shirt nope is it a water
pistol better better
possibly I mean is it a pistol that
shoots spiders
oh
what did the frustrated cannibal do
laid on me he threw up his hands
that's awesome how does a computer get
drunk
it takes screenshots
oh we'll explain don't worry here
gator in a vest
bomb Fixins we would never use them on
you or anywhere ever near you I would
never let them do that do you never let
them
right and you think they're going to
listen to you yeah
yeah point
even about me would you stop Q Ellie
Ellie I'm leaving
they're sending me to a post in the
Atlantic YouTube
tonight's my last night in Boston
oh what a conflict why did you bring me
here
because I wanted to see you
and
and I wanted to say goodbye there it is
n't easy Ellie it actually is
you just did it
oh
good bye
this is depressing what are you talking
about funniest scene in the show
ruining the comedy Terror you don't get
comedy
foreign
[Music]
oh my gosh
laughs
ah surprise I thought you'd like this
one the best so I saved it for last
Spirit Halloween is never stupid
fireflies aren't what I think they are
but they chose me
I matter to them
you matter to me first
you're my best friend
we'll miss you and and I love you let's
make out now yes let's break this
tension please one last thing
ah yeah get it on stupid why
and this music sucks
Thief
Good Taste of music
[Music]
this must have been fun to shoot
mask kiss come on come on come on come
on
oh
damn
I'm sorry
foreign
[Music]
what do we do now we're gonna figure it
out
[Music]
uh get ready to run
whoa oh my goodness oh boy oh boy oh boy
oh boy okay
oh my God
foreign
[Music]
well done
reaction huh
oh the light
no no no no no no no no no no
oh
on
damn it
it's got to be something
full of snow
quick painless
two
yeah that's two minutes
two days
we don't give that up I could just be a
poetic
[__] oh
watch option three
God lucky seems like the odds could
really go either way for a needle and
thread
come on Joel
oh yeah
give him something to bite down on
[Music]
ah let's do this yes do this
this is the first time I've ever seen a
triumphant suturing Montage
got this girl
I hate that it's over I hate that it's
over I am in a whirlwind of emotion
right now and I get so I'm mad I'm mad
after the last one and now I'm like oh
my God this is I just love I love this
show too much I just I don't like when
it ends I know I can't I know and now we
have to wait a whole other week and all
the alternate timeline where they drop
this show all in one go we're sitting
there going why could they space these
out with the week no I feel you oh I'm
exhausted right now
oh my god
oh well
hmm
we got we got some stuff to talk about
terrorists yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
boy howdy
all right Tara what did you think what
did you think
so stupid like uh it's it's a beautiful
episode I loved the Callback where rip
Ripley is your name right right Riley
Riley right Riley says do you trust me
and it's such a great callback to Joel
saying do you trust me and I remember
the same look in Ellie's eyes when he
asked that and now you get to see why
her reaction was that way when Joel
asked is because of this whole entire
episode and yeah it was it was great I'm
still mad I'm mad that it ended I'm
upset but yeah it's another like roller
coaster of a of an episode that
oh sure absolutely an emotional
rollercoaster I love the the way I mean
this one you know obviously being that
it surrounds Ellie you know is is less
of a detour than say a bill and Frank
episode but I I do love the way that
they are willing to dive into these very
intimate and very human personal aspects
of the story and then
use the conceit of the show against you
like you're constantly sitting there
going
some shoes about to draw there's gotta
be like a horde of infected just around
the corner and like it's not what the
show does but they yeah I just think
they they do this really great job of
Never Letting you forget what this world
is like what's at stake what the threats
are and yet so often it's not that stuff
that breaks through it's it's just the
real life circumstances and so I love
the back and forth of them kind of
dancing ideologically around fedra
versus Firefly life and why each of them
is sort of at least at the moment you
know falling into they're both in two
different Lanes and they both see very
differently and yet you still have this
really beautiful little relationship
between them and
yeah it's like it's harsh it's tough she
finds the bomb and and she's you know
Riley's leaving to go to the Atlantic qz
or whatever like there's there's so many
little wedges being driven and yet above
it all you just have this really
beautiful and tragic Little Love Story
unfolding and uh
and again this is another one of those
episodes where I'm like what was what
was this like in the game was it or was
it in the game like I know they expanded
heavily upon Bill and Frank for this
story uh and and I know that I believe
again do my best not to read much but I
believe Riley is a character uh because
she was alluded to before and people
were like oh man
uh and yeah to see her here now I'm just
like what was the impact in the game
what did you have to do yeah did you
have to like run around and pee and then
you got in a fight and you like you know
what I mean you had that black guy yeah
yeah definitely definitely you had to
fight uh a bunch of Boss Battles of PE
yeah and then you go talk to the one
soldier dude and then uh
I would love a version of the game where
you could just work your way up to
becoming a Federal Officer and that's it
no Grand emotionally moving story just
yep status quo done federal agent
uh but yeah yeah this was really lovely
and wonderful and I love the way they
they use them all like like great
I think anytime you're in a
post-apocalyptic infected Story You're
nodding to Dawn of the Dead when you're
in a mall but I love the way they used
it for fun and wonder
and and yeah
attention tons and tons of like what of
romantic and dramatic tension yeah like
every wonder I was like is it gonna
happen now and they went through six
wonders like what yeah man and like when
she leaves I thought that was such a
great fake out when when Ellie walks off
and she goes into that Corridor and
you're like okay here it comes now we
got a whole no it's just the
emotionality of the situation and then
having it take place on the day they
both get bit is like that much more of
like a devastating layer to add to all
this so on top of already the tragedy of
them being torn apart by circumstance
now you have like the finality of the
world that we're in and right after
Riley said she was going to stay it's
like she you of course knew that they're
both waiting they to to basically come
out or Let each other know know that
they like each other and now that it's
like finally out and they both felt safe
and
Beginning of the End sure
oh man you know Ellie's been thinking
about that forever I mean I'm sure they
both have but it's just so sad that
they had the chance to basically open up
to each other and like basically let it
be known that they liked each other and
then
within like 10 a span of 10 minutes
they're both going to die now
yeah yeah for all they know for all they
know and I and and I and I mean I don't
know if we'll ever cut back to this I
thought it was interesting where we left
off you know because you do leave off at
like the crescendo and I I appreciate
I'm curious it's as to how that'll sort
of germinate through my mind because
they do leave you off in that place
where they are just sitting together
resigned to the truth and and now really
taking in the finality of the last
minutes they'll spend together and then
using that to cut back to Joel for the
bookending contrast of like no if I have
the opportunity I will not let you slip
away because yeah I couldn't save her
because of obvious reasons but I can
save you if I have the right tools and
I'm not gonna leave you and like yeah
just the building of Joel and Ellie like
I love an episode like this that has
barely any Joel and yet you feel the
impact and the bolstering of the
relationship between Ellie and Joel
because of this even though it's such a
different kind of relationship you know
it's it's it's like a father-daughter
kind of thing and it's a it's all trust
and I thought that was a really
beautiful kind of detail like you said
at the top you know bringing back that
element of do you trust me yes and how
big of a deal that must be in this world
and two I mean the little similarities
like you know uh Riley seems musically
inclined Joel's musically inclined
they're like ways in which again in like
a non-romantic way but there are just
ways in which like their personalities
kind of match like you would get how
they would also be friends despite the
odds and she and Riley even have like a
rye sort of back and forth kind of
ribbing so it's just like a beautiful
characterization I thought and the two
of them you know this was I love an
episode two like this that will
you know isolate one or two characters
and just make it about that and let
these two actors really play and really
you know give back and forth uh I
thought storm read and Bella Ramsey both
did a terrific job here yeah I want to
see the rest of I hope that the next
episode we show the rest of them at the
mall I just I gotta know what happens
I I want to know I know everyone's like
what but why but I'm like but I wanna I
want it I want it I don't care if you
don't want it John doesn't want it I can
feel I can feel a torn Terror he's torn
there's still a couple hours left I'm
like just show it I want it I want I
want to know you want the director's cut
of this episode yes this is three hours
long it's in real time I do all the way
up until Riley finally turns I do and
then Ellie freaking out and be like what
the what what the hell why did I get so
lucky going back to find Marlene Marlene
I'm sorry but but also don't shoot
something's wrong it's been way more
than six hours or whatever the bite
range is supposed to be for you know
upper extremities they they have to they
if they get six hours they get to have
one last hurray on the mall that's maybe
the storm through Victoria's Secret not
like put anything on not anything weird
but like I don't know well I mean you
know but maybe they're both they're both
uh they seem appropriately aged together
yes you know so they could have a a
galavant through Vicky's secrets why not
and you know we were just fun not
filming you right no one would see it
would all be if it's subtitled we would
do some kind of thing where we pan to
the front of the Victoria's Secret and
then into some kind of trans
are removed of the lingerie because we
know where it went oh see he's doing it
the smarter way I was doing it like
let's just make it a whole different
thing like let's just you the camera
stays in there and then it's just a
narrator all of a sudden out of nowhere
we get to narrator voice saying and they
went and they they consummated their yes
of their Vitality but not before Ellie
put on some lingerie yes that was fit
for her maybe a boy short not a thong I
feel like she'd be in a boy shirt okay
yeah and then the narrator and then the
narrator comes out and then they walk
out and the the narrator's never heard
of again it's just a a quick blip see
that's what we need now is to figure out
uh uh who the narrator should be yes and
what uh style what cut you know each
character prefers two ladies went into
the Victoria's Secret and two hours
later they knew
absolutely in love
like that okay so you know like Kate
Blanche had to narrate or just or Terror
you know what I'm saying I mean did you
hear dude what I just did I thought you
were British now have you been lying to
me with this American accent the whole
time we've been doing the show it's so
awful I think when I do it
um friends who know it's bad say that's
a bad accent uh believe in yourself love
you're good you see John's good
money you do it right don't even worry
about it you're doing great we're doing
good super chuffed this is fun it is
yeah yeah as in the next reaction we'll
just do all birds just all of it we'll
just do all Cockney reactions from now
on
well yeah man you got any stray thoughts
I love that they ended up in a Halloween
store
Spirit Halloween's the best yeah so good
got the good masks finally yeah didn't
have to pay 150 bucks for one of them I
was like oh I would not want to dance
around in those masks I don't even want
to wear one of those masks for not
they're not cool but for more than five
minutes there you get sweaty face in
like a minute and your head smells like
rubber yeah and you can just smell your
own breath yeah and that plastic and
that hot plastic is warming up your
nasty breath and then it's like
you gotta have like a pocket full of
mints yeah even then it's
I don't think it does it justice and I
like that that infected waited till they
were at the Halloween store to attack
just so he had the best that's that's
smart you know that's camouflaging your
attack that's a good strategic move I
really wanted to see butter lettuce head
break away from the rest of the lettuce
behind him though we didn't get to see
that that was he was in that right and I
was like I want to see how he gets out
yeah they don't they don't
do much extra perspective oriented stuff
right but I would have loved to have
seen that right and I hope that before
the show
yeah if season one doesn't do season two
better do it I need to see the butter
lettuce disconnect from the other
lettuce yes yeah yes jump right out of
that salad yes go
based upon some some young ladies
or anybody really who's at the mall
that's a great Hideout though and uh and
I'm so glad they have these amazing ass
generators cheap to them all going but
that is the dream you know you got your
arcade you got your nacho living station
you got your booze got your dead guy
booze they're so good yeah I think we
would be good in the apocalypse I think
we could make it we would make it we
would make it for a long time we would
be leaders I think so yeah we could
start our own camp we don't have to be
fedra or fireflies we'll just be the
Switzerland right in the middle yeah
we're just like the the over here Camp
is what we'll call it if you want to be
chill come over here to the over here to
the over here Camp yeah that's a kiddie
pool yeah oh that's fun yeah we got a
nacho cheese machine that we got working
again yep finally found all the spare
parts thank goodness be the most
frivolous camp in the book let's be
honest is the only reason I'm here at
the over yeah I am at the over here camp
we got two books though we got all the
pun books you could ever want I love
that too the whole the pun book is like
an important or you know it's like a
significant thread and I love that that
comes up like a couple episodes ago and
you just think it's like a random thing
but it's like they don't even make a
huge deal out of it when she finds it
and then you realize like oh wait she
just found like one of her favorite
books again like how great yeah and now
here yeah you see look oh no this was
like one of their things this is the way
that she keeps
Riley alive in a way
and keeps you know some sanity in the
friggin apocalypse You Gotta Laugh a
little bit you gotta laugh a lot to stay
alive yeah live laugh love that's what I
always say always say that always say it
oh he says it always live laugh love Eat
Pray Love Eat Pray Love yeah yeah that's
what the infecteds do here is let's get
that eat pray with an e love life yeah
they learned it from Julia Robert too
who's in that movie right that was her
yeah yeah she did so much money that
movie yeah historic amounts of money
yeah because she eat she prayed and she
loved it it was all on screen yeah it
was recorded can't sue that movie for
false advertising no absolutely not no
because it's Julia she's you know we all
know she's Julia Roberts she eat she
prayed she left that's true absolute
vodka yeah and props to to the soldier
guy I've seen that actor before I
thought he did a fine job trying to
motivate Ellie yeah he was good and I
like their I like the way I guess to
kind of start to wrap it up I like that
they give you like
you know kids find out about politics
kids find out about the world around
them and take stances based on various
things and I thought they realized that
in a nice way where yeah you have these
two who are arguably being sort of
indoctrinated in different directions
and and that whole thing about like do
you even fully understand what it is
you're getting into or what it is you're
railing against and the role of you know
Spin and rhetoric and propaganda amidst
all of that uh I thought they realized
in a very sort of nice way because there
was real tension about that and you
could tell that they have currently two
very separate belief systems in certain
ways and I like the way that they use
that for tension and friction but
without it just becoming like a ah we
don't see the world the same way we
can't do anything else sort of thing
like they they never cheap out on the on
the dramatic affects that those
decisions have yeah it didn't become
overwhelming to and infect their
relationship like their relationship
stayed even though their moral ground I
guess is a little bit different in
regards to fireflies and then the QC
yeah
I'll come over the better fedra uh
acronym next time oh yeah what he did
before I mean it was good he's a fascist
fascist what about uh egotistical
fascist egotistical dumbass radical
[__] I like it ass wipes they're ass
that's why that switches it up that's
right yeah that's true yeah that's true
that's an even that's a because that's a
job then that's like a grunt job that's
not just a state of being any longer
that's like oh man what's my station in
life I'm watching the sewers yep no
wonder Riley wanted to get out there she
was going to be put at the very end of
the fedra at the very end of the acronym
it's not where you want ass wipes were
making her
you know and another [__] and uh yeah
yeah the collective [__] looking at
the other ass wipes worst version yeah
it's a bad bad bad bad bad not good not
good but you know what was good was love
it was this episode Love Is Good Love is
good Mortal Combat is good carousels are
good uh lingerie can be good yeah uh and
sneaking out to the mall also always
goody good always a good time always a
good time and uh and yeah beating people
up who take your Walkman yeah always
good always beat up someone who takes
your Walkman a Walkman should not be
touched ever ever like anyone if you
have a Walkman right now and it's on you
and somebody goes to like hey can I no
just punch him immediately don't even
stop it don't even think about it no
just say knock them out well all right
we settled that score settle you heard
it here you got any any stray thoughts
before we hit the road nope just work on
your punches if if you've got a Walkman
work on those punches subscribe hit the
like button and last but not least let's
do a little
Chris Wham off you knew this was coming
buddy listen man I want you and my
apocalypse Camp my team all right you
are the guy who people in the apocalypse
you know in the in the group will
probably give a lot of Guff to some of
the time the guy people would be like oh
man you know we gotta take action we
gotta you know be formidable we gotta
you know show people we're not to be
messed with but you would help us
maintain humanity and even if people
argue that that's an easy way to get
killed in the apocalypse we cannot no no
let go of our humanity and you you're a
selfless kind-hearted person Chris and
that's what we need to repopulate the
world with you know what I mean oh so
yeah I mean Chris is going to be
basically the he's holding down the gene
pool sure the deal over here yeah we're
gonna have to make you this at the
epicenter of the effort to repopulate
the world yes we want those kindness
genes to flow so you're gonna have to
just get down with anyone and everyone
who's willing yeah you really get a
responsible get used to it now I know
what you're thinking wow that's a lot of
responsibility but honestly no way to
avoid it man it's lots of fun yeah just
dive and avoid fun dive in dive dive
dive Chris
love you buddy stay pledged to our
little qz our little quarantine Patron
Hideout here the over here Camp the over
here Camp I like it the ohc I love you
Chris and we'll catch you next month
stay well and uh
yeah
sign off words peace
[Music]